the Joe Rogan experience but I do wish I
I get I can't wait till I get to a point
where I can have the resources to go
film a lot more content because I love
doing this yeah like I would love to go
to when you had Kalia Roundtree on and I
had commented only on a comment on
YouTube like I would love to do anatomy
of Khalil in Thailand I'll hook it up I
would love to just go to Thailand I
couldn't you know Khalil no I never met
him he's amazing
just go up buildings like he was doing
crazy but the the transformation that
guys made as a fighter from when he went
to Thailand he's back there now is in
Bangkok he's a beast man that Eric
Anders fight I was like holy [ __ ] tough
dude he's as tough as it heat it does
one thing Khalil said he never he winced
I mean he's eating leg kick after leg
kick from a guy who kicks as hard as
anybody I've ever seen that's crazy
Khalil is so fast when I was watching
throw those kicks I was like where who's
this guy it was weird how did you turn
into this guy like you see his earlier
fights and you see this what he beat go
gossip cope wasn't it book on sake not
go Constantinian off right yeah he lost
to Johnny Johnny Walker Johnny when he
went and reinvented self again Johnny
caught him with an elbow in the clinch
man he caught him with one of these
these elbows in the clinch and the K
Odom and you know he would just said
okay I have to really learn Muay Thai he
so [ __ ] I'm going to Thailand I know
he went to Thailand and I followed his
Instagram journey you know I'm watching
all his training footage and he just
fell in love with Thailand and then he
came back and I'm like this
[ __ ] right looking like Saget
from Street Fighter but like a jacked
muscular to one another I used to bat
boy to crazy that's crazy and the nicest
guy yeah he could he had a nicer guy
it's nuts to see that transformation
like to see him go from like this god it
was chubby and in this world-class
fighter well just that too but the
difference between him and well that's
hard to say right cuz the gokon sake
fight was real quick he's just crying on
the left hand and
Khalil's very fast and then see him
getting KO by Johnny Walker but then
see I saw his other fights I've seen
many fights of his but see that the
transformation I'm like what the [ __ ]
the kicks man
it was the kicks that he put it all
together and he was fighting thai style
it's like he was one more of the most
representative of Muay Thai I'd ever
seen in MMA
[Applause]